hello freak [ __ ] and then you also
have what do you think about David
branch versus Luke Rockhold tomorrow you
know I have somebody I haven't seen it
myself people are like hey have you seen
Rock Hall at Wayne's doesn't look the
same but Wayne's they had Wayne's
yesterday Oh yesterday it wins yeah I
thought when you're saying at weigh-ins
I was thinking like other wins like what
wins oh yeah forgot this today yeah
weights today the fights tomorrow though
Wayne's were today yeah yeah and people
were complaining about it I really get a
picture of Luke Rockhold from today's
weigh-in yeah I mean Luke's uh you could
argue is the best middleweight in the
world you know yet that well how can you
argue with that if Michael Bisping
knocked him out we hear me out there you
could say he's not because Michael
Bisping is the real champ but he got
caught by Bisbing right but before that
Luke Rockhold is a [ __ ] Hector
Lombard back did you hear that uh Thiago
Alves had a back out yeah okay big guy
was that what it is cuz of a hurricane
yeah there's nothing wrong with Rockhold
he looks fine the thinnest I've ever
seen Oh talking [ __ ] to each other
Rockhold should do one he what he was
sayin man
oh listen David branch don't joke dude
don't get confused if Rockhold [ __ ] up
and gets clipped by branch what is it
what are they saying to each other they
don't value branch were talking [ __ ] for
a while you're nothing yes you can hear
old versus the ninth ranked David Wright
that's anak
we'll break you up soon break you up son
[Applause]
fine
it was a great [ __ ] talking break you up
son
I'm gonna break you off son this would
be funny get all up in that what does
that mean what is it what exactly it is
that we're gonna want to fight right you
know that so what do you do you break me
out you gonna break me I mean what I
mean Luke's been gone for a while branch
is a tough customer and he's a former
world champion World Series fighting it
light heavyweight middleweight but if
you're not in the Aussie I don't give a
[ __ ] you're not fighting the same guys
do crowd Coldfire well he fought rumble
anyone went to a decision in a decision
to rumble in World Series a light
heavyweight
yeah that's rubble World Series he was
in a world beater was not long ago it
was it the rumble in the UFC also Dave
Brandt had his run in UFC before series
not good thing of the world series of
fighting does work well Gerald Harris
Kayode him with a slam in his first
fight
and then he lost to he's like it depends
like how focused motivated very skillful
he's very skilled for his ground games
very good talk about branch a radical
branch I think I'm the ground rated man
see you can't say underrated cuz he's
under way cuz he's fighting playing
grab-ass world series of fighting it's
not even close to I mean you're talking
about wmba compared to NBA I just think
he's very talented and if Rocco doesn't
take him seriously the same way didn't
take Bisping seriously he'd get [ __ ]
up a hundred percent right there's a lot
of pressure on Rockhold because he's
been gone for a while you know he needs
he needs this win my the only way I
think Rocco gets [ __ ] up is again yeah
if you didn't think I'm serious and if
you know if his heart's not in it yes if
a game rock gold shows up a game David
branch shows up Rocco destroys him you
know what rock I could see Rocco even
submitting him underrated with his top
position the top game started having a
[ __ ] tree on you his jiu-jitsu is
ridiculous very ridiculous you look at
the lyoto machida fight beat the [ __ ]
out of them from the top position look
though like when he bent down when he
got Weidman down you could see like why
moves like shocked he submitted Bisbing
with one arm yeah after
headkick but no I think I think if
Rockhold stand up is gonna be the
difference-maker in there and he's got a
long reach man you just got to make sure
that he doesn't [ __ ] up and get clipped
again but I want to see what happens cuz
when a guy like Rockhold who has a lot
to lose but not a lot to gain fights a
guy like branch who has the golden
opportunity in front of him I mean if
branch can beat Rockhold
just gigantic gimme huge and I've been
watching his training footage he sees
training [ __ ] hard just the question
is is it hard enough has he mean is he
in that kind of shape like was he at
world-class level it's really never
fought anybody like Rockhold other than
rumble in the World Series but also with
branch it's like are you gonna take the
[ __ ] governor off and go after it
because his last fight maybe it's just a
dance partner even the world city is
fine he's not Merkin guys so it's like
in the UFC he's never been that you know
the guy everyone was afraid of I'll take
the governor off and kick you in the
[ __ ] face it's a very interesting
fight because it's supposed to be if you
looked at it on paper it would be more
of a showcase fight for Rockhold
Rockhold was the former champion I don't
think David branch is ranked in the top
five
I think he's 9 yeah yeah that makes
sense so it's a big opportunity for
branch you know how old is branch I want
to say he's like thirty-second tell
about does how dare you use that's a
good thing 35 yeah so it's not too old
it's gonna be interesting and then Brock
old is like what 30 Rocco was still
pretty young I think the thing about
Rockhold he means this fight cuz now -
out of sight out of mind
Oh find a grip so everyone's like all
right let's see it oh yeah everybody
remembers Bisping clipping him knocking
a mountain and talking mad [ __ ] to him
inside the cage after he knocked him out
is this fight tonight or Saturday night
tomorrow night is it for sure tomorrow
you're doing a fight companion but
you're not gonna be here you guys do a
[ __ ] you betta instead of i watch that
lana triple G I can't miss trip I gotta
see I gotta watch a little bit of
[Music]
screens here yeah Oh watch both G want
to put one of them on youtube as well
[Applause]
[Music]